Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai une question de Manon, qui me demande : « Comment les Autochtones survivaient-ils
à l'hiver avec le froid et les tempêtes
de neige? » Manon, on a développé pas
rien qu'une technique, on avait l'art-même
de l'hiver, je pense, chez les Premières Nations,
parce que ç'a a été souvent au coeur
de l'histoire du Québec,
comment les premiers
Européens sont arrivés
et sont quasiment morts de froid.
Pareil pour la Nouvelle-Angleterre,
comment la ville qui s'appelait Saint-James
a failli mourir de faim,
et même que la tradition de Thanksgiving,
de l'Action de grâce américaine,
tourne autour de l'hiver horrible
que les Anglais ont passé.
Le froid et les Premières Nations, c'était vraiment
une question de préparation, mais aussi
d'observation de ton territoire :
Où est-ce que tu vis? Qu'est ce que les animaux
font, eux, pour se protéger du froid?
Et quelles sont les fourrures, les cuirs,
les manières de se réchauffer
qui sont adaptés à ce territoire?
C'est certain qu'on allait avoir des mocassins
qui allaient être faits pour durer l'hiver.
Donc, les mocassins
changeaient de hauteur.
Plus tu étais l'été, plus le mocassin
était bas en dessous de la cheville,
Plus tu étais l'hiver, plus le mocassin
allait monter au dessus des genoux.
pour éviter que la neige rentre.
On allait porter des fourrures, on allait doubler
avec de la mousse et, surtout, on allait
toujours s'assurer d'être au chaud
ou de se garder au chaud. Et, dans les
habitations, faire un feu ne pouvait pas
nécessairement dire que tu allais avoir
chaud, parce que pour faire un feu, il faut
faire brûler beaucoup de bois
et ça demande beaucoup d'oxygène.
Donc, souvent il y avait des techniques
qui était pensées beaucoup plus pour créer
de la chaleur que pour faire du feu.
On avait des techniques de faire chauffer
des pierres dans les habitations
qui allaient irradier de la chaleur sans créer
une perte d'oxygène ou un besoin
de faire ventiler l'habitation. Ou, on allait
faire un feu à l'extérieur
qui allait envoyer la chaleur,
mais que toute la fumée
allait rester à l'extérieur.
Plein de techniques de ce genre
ont été développées à travers
le territoire. On parle même
de la Terre de Feu, qui est
à l'extrême sud du continent.
Ce qui avait le plus surpris,
c'est qu'à l'époque, les peuples autochtones
qui habitaient en Terre de Feu
se promenaient quasiment nus, mais pensaient
constamment à se chauffer auprès d'un feu.
Tellement, que le feu était transporté
dans les canots et c'est pour ça que
quand on regardait la côte de la Terre de Feu,
on aurait dit que la côte était en feu.
Et c'est quand les Européens ont voulu
mettre des vêtements sur les communautés
autochtones que les gens ont commencé
à être malades parce qu'ils ne pensaient plus
à se réchauffer, à se garder au sec.
Et c'est là que le froid a commencé
à prendre. Mais il y a aussi le contact
avec les premiers virus européens.
Sauf que le froid, c'était une chose qui était
dépendante du territoire où tu habitais
et dont tu avais trouvé les trucs
en t'inspirant de la nature. Mais, on est
encore là, et même les longs hivers,
on pouvait y survivre en pensant à prendre
des tisanes, puisqu'on n'avait pas
les légumes et les fruits que les Européens
avaient. On prend des tisanes,
comme du cèdre, pour se donner la vitamine C
qui fait qu'on n'a pas eu le scorbut,
comme certains des premiers arrivants
au Québec. Mais, l'hiver, on s'y connaissait
et c'était en respectant le territoire,
en s'adaptant à notre territoire et en
regardant ce que les animaux faisaient
parce qu'ils étaient
les premiers à bien y vivre.
Donc, merci beaucoup pour ta question,
j'espère que j'ai pu y répondre.
Il y aurait beaucoup
d'autres histoires que je pourrais te raconter
N'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
des questions à Espaces autochtones.
Je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine.